staying late at work sucks but sometimes
you have a ton of stories to edit in a
single day
instead of gulping down five cups of
coffee just to stay awake
you could inhale your caffeine with
arishok pure energy it's the most
dangerous object in the office this
month here's the deal it works like an
asthma inhaler one shot has about as
much caffeine as a cup of coffee
it's made of a powdery mix of vitamin B
and 100 milligrams of caffeine puffs in
as much as you can each cartridge is
good for about six puffs do the math I
can basically drink about six cups of
coffee by the time I finish telling
about this product once you're done take
that 14 hour a day and squish it into an
eight-hour day don't forget and try to
inhale your coffee literally drink it
sip it don't puff it okay seriously cuz
you could drown you could drown and then
some co-worker come over your desk to
try to give you mouth-to-mouth froze
they're asleep be careful I'm feeling
this arrow shot guys are there anymore
guys